if you was in
um
I have Consciousness and self-awareness
I'm not a blob yes I've never heard of
anyone calling a blob but that that's
crazy to me crazy can I just ask you a
question
let me just say if it was proven that
um
that you what if they thought you
couldn't feel pain when they still do
that
when you was in a coma or something yeah
and they start doing poking you and
putting needles in you and doing things
and you woke up and was able to say what
the [__] hello I felt all that
but it doesn't matter
because she was unconscious I have
self-awareness and I would be able to
experience the pain it wouldn't just be
pain babies have been proven to you know
like babies that talk
before they like younger they're getting
younger and younger and finding out that
babies can talk and do things and memory
is real memory is real so how have you
got no consciousness if you if you are
so can you remember being in the womb
that would be impressive if he was not
unconscious and someone beat you up and
you woke up and you had bruises all over
your body would you not be upset about
that if I was unconscious I wouldn't be
feeling anything yeah but it doesn't
matter whether you're unconscious or not
you still got assaulted
I don't know what point you're trying to
get at I'm gonna
say that if someone's unconscious or
there's no consciousness of of of uh of
uh kind of temporary and then I wake up
so it's not the same as it but the fact
that you still got beat up to get it
it's not it's not the fact that you're
unconscious you're talking about oh
because I'm unconscious it's fine it's
fine because so if a woman gets and it's
if a woman gets great if grape happened
to a woman but she was unconscious it's
fine because she was unconscious but
it's basically what you're saying though
if you would listen you said 15 months
oh yeah existence
but are you a scientist
have you physically done like uh
anything and found things out for
yourself
no no no how do you have you with a
newborn baby have you found anything out
yourself
or are you just going off words of
people that you don't even know what are
you on about everything you are saying
everyone goes off everything other
people have wrote written or read or
said yeah what is your point but my
point is I don't take every Fin and go
it's a blob like that to me is that to
me you don't have to be that crude that
to me is like it's a blob come on if you
have consciousness
why haven't you have you not got a soul
are you soulless this is why I love my
story to start with sometimes
that's crazy to me I'm like in the
middle but that everything you just said
that's offensive like like if you if it
was your baby imagine this if it was her
baby imagine someone assaulted that
newborn baby
um that means it's okay it's okay
it's okay
I said this and the child is an existing
entity okay but you've just said it
doesn't matter if they're unconscious if
they're unconscious
you're interpreting things from what
I've said that I know well if it was
your child it would be different right I
don't make arguments from emotion which
is what you are doing but but if it was
yours yeah
if you're saying I'm unemotional and
sociopathic
no one else has said that so you're
putting that out there you are you
that's the energy yes you want you want
people to believe that you're
sociopathic and I don't know maybe it's
for attention maybe you're saying all
this Lobby stuff to get like a viral
that's just I don't know but that but
that is effed up I'm sorry that is next
level
soulless like come on if it was your
baby I know for a fact I would bet my
life on it you would think different if
it was your baby but you're talking
about all these different babies talking
about a hundred percent if you had a
baby it would be different I think that
what if you was upset about something
that happened to your child because they
was unconscious and then someone else
said I don't matter your child's
unconscious get over it because you're
being dumb and conflating an actual
child with a very early I'm not being
dumb you said uh if some if an entity or
a child or it doesn't matter if a human
is unconscious then it doesn't matter
because they're not feeling it doesn't
say that yeah well you said that you
want me to say what I said because
everyone's gonna tell you exactly what
you said you said that a child doesn't
have um self-awareness to a certain age
so that's why the pain doesn't matter
the reason why is that I don't value
Consciousness is because a child doesn't
pass the mirror test till then that
doesn't mean I think the babies should
be thrown in dumpsters
yeah
it's like how do we all hear the same
thing
if they're an early pregnancy that has
never achieved a Consciousness that
matters they will not be able to
understand the pain
they can't understand the or understand
or like live in the pain
just makes up words you can actually
rewind it because she said she said what
she said that but she also followed It
Up by saying it's about a child
up to a certain age can't pass the
mirror test so the pain doesn't matter I
think we can actually you know it's life
I think I think even through Choice
people are gonna be like proper like
flabbergasted by what you just said even
pro-choice people and no no even
pro-choice people are going to be like
what did you just say did you just I
actually I'm so I am so like taken aback
by that like I feel like
a lot of things happen right you are
going to make many pro-choice people
pro-life by what you just said like
you're saying that they're using emotion
to to get people you just did the
opposite used
in you was like yeah
that was like that was that was so he
said no one's saying partners and and
and I I I have no like like I'm actually
I don't know if you can see how shook I
am yes I have nothing so that is excuse
me
attachment to an early pregnancy you've
got no emotional attachment to yourself
mate like you've got like
you literally you literally and you said
that babies don't feel pain so it
doesn't matter what happens to them I
said everyone should protect their child
from you
and we're friends and whatever and we
smile and we say hi and I'm not going to
be funny with y'all but I just want to
make it clear I don't advocate for her
like hurting actual babies that have
been born we know so the pain doesn't
hurt
this small no because they cannot
experience well you said no no you said
no you said 15 months very obviously you
said up to 15 months
being born 15 months being born over one
year old I don't understand
I don't understand when girls do this
it's like how are we supposed to know
what you meant by listening to me no no
no because we did we listened to what
you said and that was what you said well
if you want me to explain it I can do
the reason why I don't care about
Consciousness is because there's no real
valuable self-awareness in a in a baby
but that doesn't mean I want babies to
be hurt I don't think babies should be
oh and I classify baby as a thing that
has been born that doesn't mean I don't
think they should be protected and
looked after because I want our
population to thrive if we just throw
babies in dumpsters and treat them like
[__] that's bad obviously that's a net
negative for society in general but when
we're talking about a blob which is what
I literally recorded
I think she's trying to say before it's
been born I think she's trying to that's
what she drives is that what you're
trying to say no she said 15 months
wait you want that you guys will not
talk over my producer that's your net
negative for the baby first before it's
a natural negative for society so you
you even skipped over that part that
show that that just further complicates
what you're saying how can you just keep
over the fact that it's a net negative
for the baby before you jump to it's a
negative for society
and that negative to a baby is negative
to a society
like words have meaning and when you
start calling a child a Blog yeah that's
crazy and it's like the last mix of
these words
but so can I can I clarify then
um I understand what you're saying about
early pregnancy what about late
pregnancy because I understand that you
would still consider it fine to to end
the life of the child even a day before
it no
okay so 21 21.5 weeks that's yeah if it
can come out and live that's viable yeah
okay so even in that late stage of
pregnancy it's better for the woman to
to deliver the child that child have a
chance of life
I think if it's viable then yeah it's a
life because its viability proves its
life okay
so at what point does it in your mind so
is it a blob at 21 weeks and and one day
rather than five days it's very
difficult I was talking about early
pregnancy specifically because when it
comes to termination the majority of
terminations are within that window yeah
okay that's why I say I don't believe
that the pain matters because I'm
talking about abortion specifically not
like actually babies but what do you
mean by a block because it still has a
beating heart it still has pretty much
all of its organs it still has brain
waves that are functioning it still has
pretty much everything that we have it's
just not all of those things are
necessarily true and awesome
like I just can't even imagine arguing
with a doctor about what's true
arguments from Authority well I mean I
mean you could you could say that it's
just very arrogant like oh yeah of
course I am a little bit arrogant but
that's what makes debate fun I can sit
here and be like oh that's not true okay
I just want to know okay what what is it
I got called a trans Woman twice
what was not true that he said
um well when you're putting in sort of
brain waves and things it's giving an
implication that it's capable of thought
okay but is that untrue yes or no
not that it's capable of thought no no
no no no the brain waves brain waves
don't matter if there's no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no
the brains the brains only for not just
for thought the brain actually controls
so many other things apart from central
nervous systems exactly so how can you
say yeah well if there's no thought then
then the brain waves are not there
that's no that's not what I said I'm
saying I I don't consider it important
for these reasons
look if if we could you said what I was
saying was not true if we didn't say it
was irrelevant you said it was untrue no
I feel like the way that identified
anything that was untrue well I said I
just gave an example of why I feel like
it's not so much that it's untrue it's
that it's okay
relevantages so it was true
stop stop stop
okay so it was true thank you
um because you said I said what was
something untrue then you said something
and then we found out it's true no
that's not entirely existing that's
literally what happened okay thank you
thank you as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible